repris comme les liaisons domestiques
d'une pouponnière rien al ghad
[Musique]
le gotha mondial de la nature à
bouleverser porter à marseille en
présence d'emmanuel macro le chef de
l'état qui annonce la tenue en france
d'instaurer environnementale pour sacrés
aux océans marseille umag on achève une
visite de trois jours aux airs de
campagne électorale dénoncent ses
détracteurs
[Musique]
tu assures sanitaire toujours
préoccupante en outre mer en polynésie
française de confinement et prolonger
les autorités demandent un meilleur
respect des mesures de restriction du
côté de la nouvelle calédonie la
vaccination va devenir obligatoire pour
les personnes majeures y compris les
touristes l'acceptation par ailleurs
possible son rendez-vous ce week-end
dans les centres de vaccination de
l'hexagone
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
l'attend du nouvel exécutif talibans se
prolonge en afghanistan un temps annoncé
pour ce vendredi la composition du
gouvernement ne devrait finalement pas
être dévoilée avant demain au plus tôt
depuis qu'ils ont repris le pouvoir le
15 août que les talibans multiplient les
déclarations d'ouverture discussions ces
dernières semaines avec certains de
leurs opposants comme l'ex président
hamid karzaï ou encore l'ancien vice
président abdullah abdullah les talibans
promettent un exécutif inclusif mais
l'un de leurs responsables a laissé
entendre qu'il pourrait ne pas y avoir
deux femmes ministres wade postes à
responsabilité jugeant cette option
possible uniquement à des échelons
inférieurs
de quoi provoquer la colère de militante
afghane qui ont manifesté à kaboul
aujourd'hui elle était déjà une
cinquantaine à descendre dans la rue
hier à erat
nous réclamons la liberté d'expression
la participation active et diplomatique
pour les femmes au niveau national et
international
les femmes travaillant dans tous les
bureaux concernés doivent reprendre leur
travail et ne pas être privés de leur
emploi actuel
les femmes doivent avoir un quota dans
les ministères les départements et les
ministères adjoint le nouveau
gouvernement et la communauté
internationale doivent tenir compte de
leur participation est accordée aux
femmes leur quota
les talibans doivent s'assurer que les
femmes participent à leur gouvernement
nous savons que les femmes constituent
la majorité de la population afghane si
elles ne sont pas impliqués dans des
domaines tels que l'éducation la santé
et la politique et si elles ne jouent
pas un rôle dans ces domaines au sein de
notre société le monde ne nous
reconnaîtra pas il n'entendra pas notre
voie
les talibans tiendront-ils leurs
promesses d'ouverture la composition du
gouvernement fera figure de test alors à
quoi faut-il s'attendre
nous avons posé la question à riadh
sidaoui expert du monde arabe directeur
du centre arabe de recherche et
d'analysé politique et social à genève
je pense les talibans ont tiré une leçon
de leur expérience amère avec al qaïda
je pensais donc donné des signes
d'ouverture vis-à-vis de l'occident
lagarde la regarde comme j'ai dit c'est
le qatar il se pensait là peut-être vont
former un gouvernement modéré un
gouvernement peut-être aussi lire des
femmes afin d'établir des liens avec
l'occident parce qu'il veut changer
l'image très très négative en occident
qui a eu lieu après l'attentât du 11
septembre 2001 et du côté de l'aéroport
de kaboul près d'une semaine après la
fin du gigantesque pont aérien mis en
place pour évacuer afghans et
ressortissants étrangers
l'onu a repris ses vols humanitaires
dans le nord et le sud de l'aghanistan
et des corridors humanitaires pourrait
s'ouvrir dans les aéroports afghan sous
48 heures c'est en tout cas ce que
déclare espérer le qatar le qatar devenu
l'interlocuteur
privilégié des talibans ces corridors
permettrait à l'aide humanitaire
d'entrer via l'aéroport de la capitale
et les autres qui fonctionne dans le
pays par ailleurs ariana compagnie
hainan ghana a annoncé la reprise de ses
vols domestiques
c'est la première à rétablir ses
liaisons aériennes
si les talibans ont repris le contrôle
de la quasi totalité du pays une région
résiste la vallée du panjshir bastion
historique de résistance aux talibans de
violents combats les opposent aux
combattants emmenée par le fils du
commandant massoud le chef de la
diplomatie russe s'est exprimé à ce
sujet la correspondance à moscou
d'antoine claireaux
sergey lavrov a dit espérer que les
combats entre les talibans et la
résistance anti talibans dans l'est du
pays prendront bientôt fin et laisseront
la place aux pourparlers de paix le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères a
également fait savoir qu'il était
important que le dialogue se fasse avec
toutes les composantes du peuple afghan
en ce qui concerne les solutions pour
résoudre les problèmes de l'afghanistan
par des moyens pacifiques
je pense qu'elle existe j'espère que
maintenant les dernières vagues de
conflit dans le nord de l'afghanistan et
dans la vallée du panjshir céderont la
place aux négociations trop cheap adjamé
4e afghane ce critique
et il est inévitable qu'un accord
politique comporte un compromis entre
les pachtouns qui sont principalement
représentée par les talibans même si
d'autres pachtoune eux doivent également
participer
tajik les ouzbeks et les hazara il
s'agit donc de tous les principaux
groupes ethniques d'afghanistan testeur
chez voir mais
sergueï lavrov a également laissé la
porte ouverte au dialogue avec les
talibans en soulignant que parmi les
nouveaux hommes forts de kaboul eh bien
tous ne sont pas à mettre dans le même
panier
de crabes
lorsqu'on dit qu'il est impossible de
communiquer avec eux là c'est un piège
du diable il existe une décision du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
qui ne reconnaît pas l'ensemble du
mouvement des talibans comme terroriste
mais qui sanctionne certains dirigeants
talibans pour des méfaits spécifiques
notamment des activités terroristes ou
une implication dans le trafic de drogue
et s'était rasé sa moustache et nir
barkat
et c'est dans ce contexte d'instabilité
en afghanistan que la russie avec ses
alliés de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective organise à partir du
7 septembre des exercices militaires au
kirghizstan moscou qui compte au passage
des base militaire au kirghizstan donc
mais aussi au tadjikistan pays voisins
de l'afghanistan ainsi la russie assure
à ses alliés de pouvoir répondre à toute
menace sécuritaire
retour en france troisième et dernier
jour de la visite des manuels macro à
marseille une journée placée sous le
thème de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité
après avoir passé sa matinée en mer le
chef de l'état annoncé la tenue d'un
sommet environnemental la wang hao ses
enfants 2021 ou début 2000 22 heures en
france emmanuel macron qui a inauguré en
fin de journée le congrès de l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature il se tient pour la première
fois dans l'hexagone un événement
mondial qui va durer huit jours ce
congrès est très attendue par les ong
environnementales elle espère pouvoir
peser dans les négociations avant la
cop15 prévu l'an prochain en chine des
associations qui attendent plus des
manuels maquereau en matière de lutte
pour l'environnement quel bilan tires tu
l aujourd'hui de sa politique en faveur
du climat écoutez ce qu'on pense marine
calmels présidente de l'association wild
légal france
non seulement la politique
environnementale menée par emmanuel
macron n'a pas été suffisante mais en
plus ça a été beaucoup de belles paroles
et très peu d'actes en vérité au bilan
d' emmanuel macron on attend notamment
l'autorisation donnée à total d'utiliser
de l'huile de palme à la mède on a le
retournage de veste sur l'interdiction
des néonicotinoïdes et du glyphosate de
nombreuses autres décisions qui pèsent à
son actif comme les projets montagne
d'or et encore hier la destruction des
jardins partagés à aubervilliers donc
par rapport justement à ces grandes
déclarations on voit bien que le bilan
en matière de biodiversité
il est très mauvais en france et donc
nous attendons beaucoup plus que juste
justement des grands discours politique
et on sait que malheureusement ces
congrès internationaux ce sont souvent
des belles paroles mais nous voulons des
chiffres nous voulons aussi des moyens
financiers et humains pour réellement
agir pour la biodiversité
trois jours donc de visite à marseille
pour emmanuel macron à sept mois du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle certains y voient un
déplacement aux allures de campagne
électorale alors que le chef de l'état
n'a pas annoncé sa candidature
bilan cette visite avec notera
éditorialistes alexis poulain
à hold up médiatique alors c'est une
réussite dans le sang sont évidemment on
n'a parlé que de lui pendant trois jours
mais on a vu une communication politique
grotesque et indigne l'hommage à semelle
pâtit mélangé avec un hommage en clin
d'oeil à mc fly carlito les youtuber qui
l'avait invité à l'elysée c'est
proprement salir la mémoire du
professeur assassiné par un terroriste
et même macron reste le président des
riches il a un mépris de classe afficher
les marseillais fulmine ils en ont assez
d'être utilisés systématiquement en
campagne électorale c'est pas comme si
emmanuel macron était nouveau dans le
jeu politique il était ministre de
françois hollande il était conseiller à
l'elysée quand les promesses de manuel
valls sur le plan ghetto avait été fait
là encore à un an des élections
présidentielles
étonnant je ne comprends pas pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent à part se
poser en sauveur ce qui n'est pas le cas
puisque les marseillais ne sont pas
dupes et savent bien qu'ils sont
utilisés encore une fois dans une
campagne électorale
l'exécutif face à une rentrée sociale
chargée une mobilisation se profile déjà
le 5 octobre les sujets de discussion
une tension ne manquent pas parmi eux la
réforme de l'assurance chômage mon âme
ou dès lors
le gouvernement prépare sa rentrée
sociale sur fond de crise sanitaire et
de fin du quoi qu'il en coûte même si
matignon veut prendre avec prudence ce
virage certaines réformes continue de
faire couler beaucoup d'encre notamment
l'assurance chômage porté par elisabeth
bord de la ministre du travail une
réforme qui touchera à près d'un million
de personnes en france mais pour le chef
de l'état c'est presque un texte déjà
gagné d'avancé
j'ai demandé au gouvernement dès cette
rentrée de lancer un plan massif de
formation et de requalification des
chômeurs de longue durée
c'est pour cela que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage sera pleinement mis
en oeuvre dès le 1er octobre autour
d'une volonté simple en france on doit
toujours bien mieux gagner sa vie en
travaillant qu'en restant chez soi ce
qui n'est actuellement pas toujours le
cas mais ce texte traîne de lourdes
casseroles derrière lui après avoir
relevé plusieurs inégalités et les
syndicats ont déposé un recours contre
la réforme dès lors le conseil d'état a
décidé de suspendre un des pans de la
réforme qui concerne le nouveau mode de
calcul du salaire journalier et qui
permet lui de déterminer le montant de
l'allocation versée à un demandeur
d'emploi de nombreuses incertitudes
subsistent quant à l'évolution de la
crise sanitaire et ses conséquences
économiques
ces nouvelles règles de calcul des
allocations chômage pénaliseront de
manière significative les salariés de
ces secteurs qui subissent plus qu'il ne
choisisse l'alternance entre périodes de
travail et période d'inactivité est la
rue de grenelle a donc soigné son
argumentaire cet été pour convaincre à
nouveau le conseil d'état d'autoriser
dans un mois le dernier volet de son
plan m et les partenaires sociaux
restent farouchement opposés à cette
réforme malgré elle et quelques
ajustements est philippe martinez de
secrétaire général de la cgt elle la
qualifie d'injuste cette réforme est
injuste car elle va pénaliser ceux qui
sont déjà dans une situation difficile
croire que c'est en tapant sur les
demandeurs d'emploi les plus précaires
qu'on va faire face aux difficultés de
recrutement c'est complètement
inconséquent la ministre s'est rendu
compte que dans cette réforme injuste
certaines personnes étaient encore plus
pénalisées que les autres mais au delà
des congés maternité et des arrêts
maladie c'est bien l'ensemble de cette
réforme que nous contestons alors qu
emmanuel macron assuré que la réforme
serait mise en oeuvre dès le 1er octobre
elle la bataille est loin d'être gagnée
pour l'exécutif la réforme elle sera
passée au crible par les juges du
conseil d'état le gouvernement n'est
donc pas à l'abri d'un énième
rebondissement
important maintenant sur la situation
sanitaire la vaccination contre le coc
ville va devenir obligatoire en nouvelle
calédonie la mesure a été votée à
l'unanimité par le congrès de nouméa
elle concerne toutes les personnes
majeures résident dans l'archipel louis
entrent en avant le 31 décembre aucune
sanction ne sera imposée à l'exception
des professions en première ligne comme
les professionnels de santé passée cette
date ils encourront une amende
équivalente à 1500 euros l'archipel ne
recense pourtant aucun décès lié au co
vides et seuls 136 cas de contamination
depuis le début de l'épidémie mais son
gouvernement craint une vague épidémique
à celle à semblable à celle que connaît
la polynésie française je vous propose
d'écouter ce député
c'est une horreur absolue là bas or nos
populations sont dans un contexte
sanitaire et culturel équivalent des
comorbidités massive et un mode de vie
complètement grégaire ou des populations
vivant tribus et multiplie les
rassemblement spirituel
si le virus entre chez nous on connaîtra
une situation au moins équivalente à la
polynésie voire pire
la polynésie française ou le confinement
est prolongée jusqu'au 20 septembre soit
quinze jours de plus que prévu hier plus
de 380 malades étaient hospitalisées
dont 58 en réanimation une centaine de
réservistes doivent arriver de
l'hexagone à la fin de la semaine pour
renforcer les équipes médicales sur
place 50 ont déjà débarqué hier les
autorités locales travaillent également
à la mise en place du pass sanitaire
dans la collectivité elles ont déjà
annoncé
durcissement des contrôles écouter
notre situation sanitaire est encore
aujourd'hui extrêmement préoccupante et
fragile dans ces conditions il est donc
nécessaire de poursuivre la mobilisation
contre le virus avec un très haut niveau
d'exigence j'en appelle et l'a
solennellement au civisme et à la
vigilance en journée il y a encore trop
de personnes qui se déplacent sans motif
légitime et j'ai demandé aux forces de
police et de gendarmerie d'être
davantage présentes sur les routes et de
renforcer leur contrôle et comment ces
mesures sont-elles accueilli réaction de
maillane ou routier secrétaire
territorial du snetaa fo polynésie on
est à venir pour dire qu'il fallait
peut-être ne mettant pas c'est un
confinement
un peu plus strictes pour que l'on
puisse ajouter à
la fin de propagation du virus est
encore beaucoup de déplacements
pour des motifs qui sont pas forcément
légitime donc aujourd'hui à beaucoup de
professions pour lesquelles on a dû
fermer des entreprises pour lesquelles
aujourd'hui ils ont plus de chiffre
d'affaires qui souhaiteraient pouvoir de
le travailler normalement comme
c'était le cas il ya plus de deux
semaines
et ailleurs en france situation
hospitalière sous tension dans les
bouches-du-rhône la martinique et la
guyane en cause la propagation du
variant delta alors qu'une nouvelle
souche de coronavirus inquiète désormais
la communauté scientifique quentin
mauclair
l'été à peine terminée le coc vide
repointe le bout de son nez le variant b
1 621 rebaptisé mu inquiète les
instances sanitaires mondiales ce lundi
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
classé le muc dans sa liste de variants
à suivre l'inquiétude de l'om s portent
notamment sur sa résistance aux vaccins
en raison d'une mutation similaire aux
variants gamma ou bêta la variante mu à
une constellation de mutation qui
indique des propriétés potentiel
d'évasion immune les données
préliminaires présentés au groupe de
travail sur l'évolution du virus
montrent une réduction de la capacité de
neutralisation des sérums deux
convalescents et de vacciner similaire à
celle observée pour le variant bêta mais
cela doit être confirmés par d'autres
études
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
l'agencé de santé britanniques estiment
selon les premières données que
l'efficacité du vaccin sur le mur serait
équivalente à celle qu'on observe sur le
bêta soit 77% pour les deux doses de
vaccin arn selon le land cette régionale
fc rock détecté pour la première fois en
janvier dernier en colombie le variant
mu s'est ensuite propagé en amérique du
sud et en europe cette variante
représentent 39% des nouvelles
contaminations en colombie et 13% en
equateur mais à l'échelle mondiale la
part du vaillant nu dans les nouveaux
cas reste inférieure à 0,1 pour cent
selon l' oms en belgique sept résidents
entièrement vacciner d'une maison de
retraite sont décédées en l'espace de
deux semaines après avoir contracté
cette forme du coc vite 19 en france si
le vaillant delta est majoritaire santé
publique france suit de près l'évolution
du mu dans l'hexagone les données
expérimentales préliminaire de public
health england suggère une diminution de
la neutralisation par les anticorps
poste infectieux ou post vaccinaux et
ses résultats de laboratoire suggère que
b 1 621 pourrait avoir des propriétés
d'évasion immunitaire similaire à celle
du voc bêta à l'heure actuelle on ne
sait pas comment le b 1 621 se
comportera par rapport à delta et ce
variant fait l'objet d'une surveillance
attentive
même si une transmission accrue par
rapport à delta semble peu probable au
25 août 2021 santé publique france
recensait 105 criblage du var y en eu
depuis son apparition sur le territoire
en mai dernier les autorités sont aux
aguets pour que ce nouveau variant ne se
mue par an une nouvelle vague de kovy de
19,1 direction le texas aux etats-unis
c'est une victoire majeure pour les
opposants à l'avortement la cour suprême
refuse de suspendre une loi cet état du
sud américain qui interdit d'avorter
après six semaines de grossesse même en
cas de viol ou d'inceste on retrouve
tout de suite à washington notre
correspondant thomas monnaie
bonjour thomas c'est une loi qui
provoque de vives réactions aux états
unis explique henno
oui il faut d'abord rappeler le contenu
de cette loi qui rend illégale toute
procédure d'avortement au-delà de six
semaines de grossesse et la spécificité
de cette loi c'est que la responsabilité
revient aux citoyens de la faire
appliquer avec un système de
dénonciation et même de récompenses dix
mille dollars pour chaque citoyen qui
dénoncerait une personne qui aurait
recours à une ivg au delà donc de ses
six semaines de grossesse vous l'avez
dit pas d'exception ni pour les cas de
viol ou les cas d'inceste alors
normalement ces lois elles sont bloquées
par la cour suprême des etats unis cela
fait maintenant 50 ans depuis qu'une loi
a été votée au niveau fédéral en 1973
que liv et j'ai aidé autorisé aux états
unis mais cette fois donc la cour
suprême n'a pas suspendu cette loi
promulguée au texas cinq juges sur les
neuf qui siègent à la cour suprême ont
décidé donc de ne pas suspendre cette
loi une décision qui a provoqué
l'indignation du président américain joe
biden qui a d'abord publié un communiqué
quelques instants plus tard pour
s'offusquer à la fois de la décision de
la cour suprême des etats unis aussi
évidemment de ces décisions des
autorités texanes et puis joe biden a
finalement pris la parole c'était il ya
quelques instants ce vendredi il a été
interrogé sur ce sujet de cette loi
contre l'avortement dans le texas
écouter ce qu'en dit joe biden
la chose la plus pernicieuse concernant
cette loi au texas c'est que d'une
certaine manière cela crée un système
justicier où les gens sont récompensés
pour des actes de délation enfin bref
cela me paraît je sais que c'est
ridicule mais cela paraît presque anti
américain je ne parle pas du débat je
respecte les gens qui pensent ça qu'ils
ne soutiennent pas la loire au viread je
respecte leur point de vue je respecte
ceux pour qui la vie commence au moment
de la conception je le respecte je ne
suis pas d'accord mais je le respecte je
ne vais pas imposer ma vision aux gens
alors en attendant d'éventuelles mesures
prises par le gouvernement américain
vous l'avez compris joe biden marche
quelque peu sur des oeufs sur ce sur ce
sujet il y à d'autres responsables
politiques qui ont pris des initiatives
c'est le cas par exemple de la
présidente démocrate de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi qui a fait
savoir qu'elle voulait voter un projet
de loi d'ici la fin du mois de septembre
pour empêcher une quelconque loi
similaire de voir le jour à l'avenir aux
états unis on a aussi appris que la
commission des affaires judiciaires du
sénat allait se réunir et procéder à une
audition sur cette question de cette loi
donc qui a été promulguée cette semaine
dans le texas en tout cas cette loi elle
relance un débat récurrent aux etats
unis puisque évidemment de nombreux
états conservateurs ont tenté ces
dernières années de restreindre l'accès
à l'avortement dans leur est alors
souvent évidemment eh bien ces lois
elles ont été suspendues par la cour
suprême et bien pas cette fois ci et en
parallèle il ya aussi les associations
pro ivg qui elle se mobilise depuis
plusieurs semaines que cette loi est
dans les tuyaux au texas pour justement
alerter l'opinion et maintenant elle
demande au président américain joe biden
de prendre des mesures très concrètes et
très rapide pour contrer les effets de
cette loi qui a été promulguée au texas
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
merci beaucoup thomas et au reste aux
etats unis ce que le bilan s'alourdisse
au moins 44 morts après le passage de la
tempête ida à new york et sa région le
bilan humain
mouret pour le new jersey état voisin de
la mégapole américaine avec 23 victimes
pour la plupart noyées dans leurs
voitures emportées par les eaux new york
enregistrait l'eau - 13 décès des
personnes souvent pris au piège donc
sous sol de leur immeuble il est tombé
80 mm de pluie en une heure à central
park c'est un record
le chef de la police new yorkaise
recense également de nombreux dégâts
matériels écouter
nos pensées et nos prières vont aux
familles qui sont en deuil aujourd'hui
le système de transport en commun a été
extrêmement affectés par la tempête
toutes les autres lignes de train ont
été suspendues en raison de la montée
des eaux
je demanderai à tous le monde d'appeler
vos voisins votre famille et vos amis
pour vous assurer qu'ils vont bien nous
poursuivons les enquêtes et les
contrôles dans les zones touchées par la
tempête
et les habitants sont surpris a battu
regardez les réactions de certains
d'entre eux font des courants les dégâts
c'est la première fois que je viens
depuis la nuit dernière
l'eau a commencé à monter vers 23 heures
vers 00h30 ou une heure il y avait
environ un mètre d'eau puis dans les
deux heures qui ont suivi elle a atteint
environ deux mètres et ça a pris environ
sept heures pour qu'il se retire jusqu'à
maintenant
j'avais vraiment par mon mari a dû se
réveiller vers 4 heures du matin juste
pour voir le niveau d'eau et où ça en
est et j'étais terrifiée par ça c'était
ma peur je ne voulais pas que l'eau
arrive dans l'appartement donc j'étais
effrayée
[Musique]
je ne peux même pas compter mes pertes
en ce moment vous savez c'est comme ça
que je nourris ma famille j'ai trois
beaux enfants une femme et une bonne
affaire c'est tout ce que je voulais
dans ma vie c'était mon rêve et j'ai
l'impression d'avoir tout perdu
maintenant
j'ai vraiment le coeur brisé par tout ce
qui s'est passé je ne sais même pas
comment revenir de ça maintenant je ne
peux même pas expliquer ce que je dois
faire pour faire les choses bien
en parle maintenant en tunisie sous des
élus montent au front pour exiger la
faune des mesures exceptionnelles
décidées par président rails ça y est
c'était le 25 juillet face à la
prolongation du gel des affaires
parlementaires et de la levée l'immunité
des députés il crée une remise en cause
des acquis démocratiques
les précisions de notre correspondant à
tunis ça me chez lui ils sont une
cinquantaine de députés principalement
de l'opposition avoir signé une pétition
contre les actions du président et kaïs
ier dans leur ligne de mire les mesures
exceptionnelles déclaré par le chef de
l'état au lendemain de son coup de force
du 25 juillet dernier mettant fin aux
fonctions du chef du gouvernement et
suspendant l'activité des parlementaires
initialement prévu pour une durée de 30
jours ces mesures ont été prolongées par
le chef de l'état le 24 août dernier
pour une durée indéterminée kaïs ça y
est bien décidé à combattre la
corruption et à nettoyer la scène
politique tunisienne fait cavalier seul
faisant fi de toute critique de
l'opposition pour les parlementaires
signataires c'est une atteinte aux
acquis démocratiques de la révolution de
2011 est une entrave aux libertés
fondamentales
écoutez à ce sujet yahi des ailes ou me
député indépendant et ancien membre de
calcul l'aise la formation politique de
nabil karoui c'est une alerte en fait
parce que les libertés fondamentales
sans remise en cause sans altérer d'une
façon brutale à travers les agissements
du président de la république qui
concentre tous les pouvoirs entre ses
mains c'est à dire l'exécutif tout
l'exécutif on n'a pas de gouvernement le
législatif puisque la des sceaux
pratiquement de fait il a dissous
l'assemblée c'est pas un simple gel et
le j'ai dû si judicieux puisque il se
proclame
président de du parquet nous on demande
à ce que cette crise soit résolue d'une
façon politique qui dit un consensus un
débat au sein du parlement pour le cas
échéant
promulguer une loi 2 de
d'élections anticipées de dissolution de
l'assemblée de convocation à une
élection anticipée sachant que la
priorité aussi aujourd'hui de moeurs
l'institution de la cour
constitutionnelle puisque la seule
limite à cet arbitraire c'est
l'indépendance de la magistrature la
cinquantaine de signataires exigent des
réponses claires et rapides de la part
du chef de l'état notamment sur la durée
d'application des mesures
exceptionnelles à travers cette pétition
qu'ils veulent citoyenne et démocratique
il espère un retour au cheminement
constitutionnel par la levée des
restrictions imposées aux droits humains
la garantie d'un procès équitable pour
les députés et les hommes d'affaires
poursuivi ainsi que la tenue d'élections
législatives anticipées
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain journal dans
une trentaine de minutes à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions et du
symbolisme en terme de timing ce sera
absolument parfait et ils veulent une
fanfare d'un possible pour la coupe du
monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le fou ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent si c'est que
dalle en fait c'est peanuts donc si vous
voulez aujourd'hui être affiché à
travers tous les continents avoir une
image et en plus un an de la coupe du
monde c'est rêver pour le qatar parce
qu'on va reparler d'eux et encore pour
des raisons d'ailleurs plutôt mélioratif
plutôt plat
on vit tous les jours sans